the opening scene features a couple
named will and Sam who are expecting
their first child however there is a
problem they aren't married yet as a
result will must seek permission from
her parents particularly her strict
Father Tom who Harbors disapproval for
reasons unknown Sam advises will to go
easy on her father and not to bring up
the particular boat incident when will
put Barnacles on his balls and called
himself the
captain not that funny following this he
travels from Seattle to Chicago to meet
her parents as will arrives at his
destination Sam's mother Paula welcomes
him inside things get awkward as soon as
he meets Tom who treats him quite coldly
here we learn that Tom is a retired
soldier who served in the armed forces
for more than 30 years later at dinner
they discuss helping will and Sam on
purchasing a house but Tom is also
concerned about protecting his money in
case the two break up he believes that
will influence uenced his daughter to
move away from her parents hearing this
will gets angry and reveals that it was
actually Sam's idea to relocate he also
discloses that it's specifically because
she doesn't want her father breathing
down her neck all the time this causes
an argument to ensue between the two and
as a result will leaves without
mentioning about the pregnancy or the
wedding the next day Sam calls him
before his flight back she seems to be
aware of what happened the previous
night and decides to talk to him once he
reaches the air report in the midst of
their conversation a strange sound
emanates from Sam's background causing
her to be scared she claims that
something is wrong but before they can
discuss further the line goes dead will
repeatedly attempts to call back and
also leaves a voice message but he is
unable to reach her he then hurries to
the airport to catch his flight to
Seattle only to discover that all
flights are cancelled there is a TV news
report discussing preliminary reports on
a seismic event off the west coast of
the us that is disrupted electrical
power and telecommunication unable to
comprehend the situation will decides to
return to Sam's parent's apartment as he
exits the airport there is already a
huge traffic jam with people trying to
get cab rides will then hands extra
money to a cab driver and secures
himself a ride upon arriving at the
apartment he finds that Sam's parents
are already packing up to leave not
being able to reach their daughter
worries them as well so Tom decides to
drive to Seattle and get his daughter
rather than waiting for flights he asks
if Will is coming with them to which the
latter says yes but only if you call me
the captain after this the two set off
on a long road trip to Seattle as they
drive out they witness that the city has
already turned very chaotic sometime
later they arrive at a gas station where
a huge pile of cars and people are all
fighting for supplies while filling up
the gas some local goons try to
intimidate will for money Tom cleverly
plays along and tells them that he has
cash in the trunk however however he
surprises the thugs by brandishing a gun
scaring them away as they resume their
Journey will complains to Tom about why
are you carrying a firearm in response
dad says that if the goons had taken
their car and money it would already
have been game over after a while of
driving they encounter another problem
the Army is closed off the interstate
for safety reasons but upon invoking his
prior service as a marine officer and
explaining the situation Tom manages to
persuade them to let his car through
following this the two Drive non-stop
for the entire day as it gets dark they
are pulled over by a police car however
it turns out that the driver is not a
police officer but rather a civilian
with a shotgun the man opens fire
prompting will and Tom to get inside
their car and speed away after a brief
chase the duo manages to escape
momentarily using another abandoned
vehicle to block the crazy man's path
they then exit the highway and take a
narrow way suddenly some deers come into
their path causing them to swerve and
crash because of course they do due to
this the pursuer catches them again
little did they know that they were
dealing with deer man as the man holds
will at gunpoint Tom manages to attack
him from behind and knock him down this
commotion causes Tom's ribs to get
fractured in the aftermath of this event
they use the police vehicle and Tow
their damaged car to a nearby
reservation there they meet a female
mechanic named Ricky who agrees to
repair their car but not a higher price
in the midst of this they witness an
usual sight a flock of birds flying in
an odd formation after the repair Tom
worries that their car might break down
again knowing that Ricky wants to go to
California he asks her to accompany them
in their Journey the repair girl is
initially hesitant but she eventually
agrees when Tom offers her a huge sum of
$2,000 following this the trio embarks
on their road trip along the way they
observe another anomaly their compass
needle continuously rotates indicating
disrupted magnetic fields in in the area
while discussing this a car in front of
them suddenly loses control and crashes
because of course it does rushing to the
scene to check they find all the
occupants dead just then a group of
armed men arrives prompting the trio to
drive away without getting into any
further trouble later on they pull over
on the side of the road to refill gas
into their vehicle during this the
clouds form a menacing shape and the
weather starts getting worse soon after
a storm of lightning and rain ensues
compelling them to seek shelter under a
bridge until it stops as the days pass
by things only get more and more intense
the temperature rises prompting will to
increase the AC in the car at one point
they decide to pull over at an abandoned
water park in search of some supplies
Ricky who is excited to see a pool jumps
in expecting cool water however the
temperature rise has warmed the water as
though the Devil Himself took a pee in
there the two guys laugh at her action
and then proceed to scavenge some
supplies before resuming their Journey
as the evening Dawns they notice that
the fields on the side of the road have
caught fire despite this they continue
to drive forward soon after they are
stopped by a woman who pleads for help
claiming that she has a flat tire the
trio in a generous gesture steps out of
their car to help her but much to their
shock but not mine it turns out to be a
trap as a group of armed men surround
them they hold the three of them at
gunpoint and steal all of their gasoline
reserves will requests them to leave
them with just one gas can but his
please fall on deaf ears they rob
everything and abandon them to die in
the middle of the road knowing that they
are doomed without fuel the three decide
to give them chase and reclaim their
supplies after an intense Chase they
eventually catch up to the thugs Ricky
shoots out the tires causing their car
to flip and crash with the surrounding
fire and the crashed cars leaking gas
tank they barely have enough time to
take their gasoline back but fortunately
they manag to retrieve a can of gas
before the car explodes in the aftermath
all three of them are visibly distressed
but Ricky is even more upset as she
believes that she killed them she also
regrets accompanying them in this hell
will tries to console her saying that if
they didn't do so they would be dead
however she is overwhelmed by the guilt
so she asks will to pull over she then
exits the vehicle and sits down on the
side of the road believing that she
needs some time alone to calm herself
down will and Tom get inside the car and
fall asleep the following morning the
two men wake up to find Ricky and her
belongings gone unable to do anything
about it they continue on their journey
to Seattle over time Tom's Health starts
to deteriorate due to his fractured ribs
after a while of driving they come
across a train wreck where they make a
stop will approaches the train to check
for some gas while Tom rests in the car
during this Tom's lung starts to
collapse making it difficult for him to
breathe seeing him suffer will rushes
back to him and injects a needle
alleviating the pressure in his lungs
back in the car the two finally begin to
open up to each other Tom who knows that
he won't survive much longer has will
promis that he will always take care of
Sam he also reveals that he knows about
his daughter's pregnancy because she had
told him that same night that they had
had an argument it is at this moment
that will brings up the boat incident in
which Tom's precious boat got wrecked
all because will put Barnacles on his
ball will finally discloses that it was
Sam who is riding it in an inebriated
State hearing this Tom believes that
will is a good man and he will be a good
father as well after a while the two
come across a bridge where they are
stopped by a gang of armed men on
motorcycles will tries to explain the
situation to them but he can sense that
they won't let them go in a swift action
he reverses the car as the motorcycles
follow them Tom grabs a pistol and blows
up an abandoned truck allowing them to
evade the gang but tragically Tom
succumbs to his wounds in the process
although saddened will continues driving
until the car breaks down not wanting to
leave Tom's body to rot will douses
gasoline all over the vehicle and burns
it down he then continues the rest of
his journey on foot it's the fifth day
of the journey will is walking along a
desolate Road when he notices a Jeep
approaching from behind he signals for a
lift and the vehicle stops a man walks
out of the vehicle and degrees to help
him since he has his wife and a little
daughter inside the Jeep the man asks
will to hand over his firearm following
this will leads them to his estranged
father's empty house in Idaho where they
all take some rest here will strikes a
deal with them he gets their vehicle in
exchange for them staying at his
father's house for 3 weeks the man
agrees to the deal and as a result will
gets back to his seemingly NeverEnding
Journey as he gets closer to Seattle he
sees that the city is almost completely
destroyed the mystery thickens as will
reaches 30 Mi outside of town where he
notices dead victims buried in their
cars under a thick layer of Ash upon
entering the city the environment is
even more ravaged with debris and bodies
littered everywhere he finally reaches
Sam's apartment only to discover that
the entire half of the building is gone
just then he sees a note that reads come
find me and there's an address as well
without delay he drives towards the
specified location using a paper map if
Will were 30 or younger and didn't have
Google Map Ms he'd be completely boned
shortly after will arrives at a cabin
where he's greeted by a man firing at
him he is a former neighbor from their
apartment building named Jeremiah just
then Sam runs out of the cabin and the
couple finally have an emotional reunion
Jeremiah who has been staying with Sam
and helping her seems to have developed
feelings for her hence he seems to be a
bit jealous later that night will is
awakened by an earthquake he goes out to
see the Northern Lights in the sky they
don't really look like that you know he
also notices Sam and Jeremiah hanging
out at a campfire as will joins them
Jeremiah starts talking about what is
causing all of these events he reveals a
deep paranoia convinced that the
disaster is not natural but the result
of an elaborate attack according to him
a man-made bomb was dropped on the coast
and caused the Fallout however will
completely disagrees with his theory
based on what he is witnessed out there
on the road the following morning he
spots Jeremiah inspecting his Jeep when
he confronts the man the ladder takes
him into the woods and tries to kill him
Jeremiah says that he wants Sam to be
only his however before he can pull the
trigger will shoots him down in
self-defense soon after a volcanic
eruption triggers a massive burst of
fire Ash and shock waves creating a
pyroclastic flow seeing this will
hurriedly take Sam and the two speed
away from the all engulfing Cloud barely
staying ahead of it eventually they
managed to outdistance it as it subsid
the movie ends as they head north hoping
to find a safe place subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching